a clear majority of americans are
willing to wear masks indoors at all
times
indefinitely according to a new poll
from axios and ipsos that is the bad
news
the bad news is that americans have lost
their minds dignity and fashion sense
the good news is that it is mostly just
the libs
so this same poll shows that only 38 of
republicans are willing to wear masks
indoors all the time
compared to a whopping 82 percent of
democrats who are ready to muzzle
themselves
this is a massive difference about one
of the most basic aspects of our lives
how we present ourselves in public how
we smile how we speak how we breathe
does this difference between the left
and the right
come about because our brains work
differently maybe maybe a little bit
is it because we view life and death
differently maybe that plays a role too
but the biggest factor here at play is
right before your very eyes and the libs
are getting really nervous about it
it's the media i'm michael knowles
that's the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from sdog556 who
says i feel like the only person from
america who should be going to the
beijing olympics is eric swalwell so he
can see his ex-girlfriend that's true
that this is the really the toughest
part of the diplomatic boycott is that a
sitting member of congress the democrat
eric swalwell might now not be able to
see his chinese spy girlfriend that he
slept with for a very long time that
that's really sad people
you know sure the athletes we talk about
the athletes or the coaches or
but what about eric swalwell how's he
going to have a good time
when you want to have a good time when
you want to protect your assets and your
wealth i would recommend you check out
acre gold silver and gold silver and
gold everyone wishes for silver and are
you like yukon cornelius do you wish for
gold specifically
well acre will let you get your hands on
some gold now you might say michael i
don't have a whole lot of money what if
i told you you could start investing in
physical gold for as little as 30
a month
you can i know you'll probably call me a
liar but it's true you can acre has this
ingenious way to invest where when your
gold stash reaches the price of their
gold bars monthly monthly you subscribe
to the gold 30 bucks a month then once
it reaches that threshold they'll
discreetly ship acre gold to your house
acre has introduced a new 100 a month
subscription to a 5 gram gold bar if you
want to up the ante great way to start
getting invested in physical precious
metals i have enjoyed investing in
physical precious metals and
specifically
in acre gold go to getacre gold.com
knowles right now
start investing in physical gold today
make sure you go to that url because
acres giving away a gold bar to qualify
for the giveaway tweet or post why you
should be the recipient and mention at
get underscore acre that is getacre
gold.com slash knowles i have said from
the beginning the masks are a political
symbol
whatever they do or don't do medically
or for public health or whatever we can
all debate that dr fauci can debate that
with himself because he's held opposite
views on the question
whatever you talk about the medical side
it is a political symbol
when i walk down the street and i see
someone wearing a mask i can know with a
great deal of certainty i am looking at
a lib that was true basically for the
the whole epidemic but it's especially
true now when i see someone not wearing
a mask i know i'm looking at a
conservative i was on an airplane
yesterday and you look and you the
degree to which the mask is below the
nose the the lower the mask is on the
face
you can know almost with 100 certainty
the more conservative the person is that
you are
looking at
how did it get this way how did we get
to the place where more than four out of
five democrats in america are willing to
muzzle themselves with that filthy
disgusting cloth indefinitely
is it just because they're naive is it
just because they're a little bit kooky
maybe sure i really think it's the media
though
because i
i peruse cnn every now and again i guess
i'm a masochist maybe that's my kink i
don't know i look at the new york times
i read the washington post and if if i
were just reading those news outlets and
just watching those tv shows i would be
scared to death
of the
the omicron
and the delta and the phi beta kappa and
all of them i would think that i were on
the verge of death
because the bubonic plague were all
around me because those news outlets lie
but they are very effective at lying
now thankfully that's not all that i
read and listen to it's not all that you
read and listen to that's probably why
you're not
extremely neurotic about the woofloo
and
increasingly you have the opportunity
not to
pay attention to those fear-mongering
demagogues on cnn and the new york times
and everywhere else and the libs are
really upset about this axios
just ran
a hit piece on conservatives
called
right wing builds its own echo chamber
and it shows the monthly downloads of
u.s right-wing apps
so it's not just our podcasts which are
some of the top podcasts in the world
and it's not just our website which is
one of the most
widely shared i actually the most widely
shared uh news organization on facebook
for instance and it's not just
it's not just our properties it's the
it's the app in particular
we're we're number one we're number one
then there's the me you see the me we
network here you see blaze parlor
newsmax oh and so these are all
all these conservative apps and axios is
really upset that we're building our own
echo chamber
now of course no matter how well
facebook or no matter how well daily
wire does on facebook sure we're the
number one publisher on facebook
but conservative stuff broadly is
actually a very small portion of
facebook
yeah daily wire is top of the heap but
we're just one outlet even if you take
into account all the different
apps and conservative outlets it's it's
a drop in the bucket compared to the
left-wing media landscape
and so
it doesn't matter how well one company
does
generally the left is going to get its
views out there more effectively
now they're being threatened a little
bit because the right is growing
tremendously specifically daily wire not
even just to to our own horns but the
left has given us an opportunity the
left keeps canceling people in movies
canceling people in tv canceling people
in sports turning people off because of
their awful politics and then we just
scoop it all up that's why we're joking
about how we're about to hire chris
cuomo it's because it seems like
everyone we're not going to hire chris
but everyone that gets canceled we hire
them up they're really good talents and
then
we help to grow and then we go further
up on this list and the libs cry about
it
they're building an echo chamber
so what if we are
it's not an echo chain it is an echo
chamber but it's not an echo chamber in
the sense that the libs think
the libs have a very large echo chamber
their echo chamber spans sea to shining
scene it's the entire media landscape
and their voices echo and they
reverberate and they're just kind of the
background noise and everyone believes
the nonsense that they say and we want
our voices to echo too
we want our voices to be out there and
for when people think about some
political issue to think about the daily
wire report they heard about it to think
about that thing that maybe i said on my
show that debunks the nonsense that they
heard from the new york times or the
washington post it's good to have your
voice echo
the the libs have had their voices
echoing for decades and dec i mean at
least 50 years and and really longer
than that
and it has helped them utterly transform
the country and now we're going to go
fight back and we're having a lot of
success at that and they can cry about
it but too bad you did this to
yourselves you have given conservatives
an opportunity
because of your
obvious dishonesty
and your corruption and your failures
and now we're fighting back and that's
that's too bad for you isn't it speaking
of the media and the left-wing echo
chamber that reverberates around our
country
fredo
fredo cuomo because he has not yet
gotten the call from daily wire
he's waiting by his phone please ben
call me give me the the chris cuomo show
on the daily wire because that hasn't
happened yet he needs to make a buck and
so how's he going to do it he's going to
sue cnn there's a report out now
that cuomo is hiring lawyers and
preparing to file a lawsuit over the
remainder of his four-year contract from
last year
uh the contract was reportedly worth six
million dollars a year
six million bucks this jerk was i gotta
call ben man i gotta renegotiate my
contract by
the few orders of magnitude i think so
that that leaves
18 million to 20 million dollars on his
contract that would be owed
cnn says we're not giving you a penny
chris cnn says they have quote no
intention of paying this is through a
cnn insider so they're speaking
anonymously but this is clearly coming
from cnn they have no intention of
paying cuomo a penny because if he gets
a settlement there would be an uproar
furthermore another another source says
cnn has a standard morality clause in
their contract that says that if the
employee does anything of disrepute they
can be immediately fired if
cnn enforced the morality clause
that if you fall into disrepute you if
you do anything of disrepute rather you
can be fired there would not be anyone
in the cnn building there would be
tumbleweed blowing through the hallways
of cnn
oh wow oh we just found out this is
breaking news we just found out chris
cuomo is andrew cuomo's brother
wow we just found that he we just found
out he's mario cuomo's
son
oh wow big news all right
the morality clause goes into effect
give me
a break
the network that employs jeffrey tubin
is now puffing their chests about a
morality clause is that so
whatever cuomo did and who knows now the
one thing we know cuomo did is help his
brother which he was obviously going to
do and he's obviously been doing for his
entire life
now there are these sort of
dubious allegations of vague sexual
harassment that it's clear cnn is
leaking to try to get out of paying him
the rest of his contract
that they don't seem particularly
credible necessarily maybe they need we
need to see more evidence for that
we know what jeffrey toobin did
we know that jeffrey toobin on a zoom
call with colleagues exposed himself
and
performed an act of intimacy with
someone that he loves
that guy's still working that guy's
still on air at cnn give me a break it
has nothing to do with morality
it has everything to do with political
usefulness
the cuomos are no longer useful
to cnn cnn hired chris cuomo because the
cuomo family
was a relatively minor but still
substantial democrat political dynasty
because now everyone forgets about him
but his dad mario cuomo was a very
important democrat politician who
actually popularized the idea that you
can be personally against abortion but
somehow politically for abortion and it
was a way to give nominally catholic
politicians a way out to adhere to the
leftist sacramental view of abortion
while still pretending to be catholic
but now they're done and the
mario's out andrew's out and so fredo's
out too
and now they're gonna
bicker about morality and i am here to
see it because the corruption that we've
been seeing leak and leak more and more
for years
is very likely about to break out into
the open
again now when you don't want things to
break out or break in and you want to
keep yourself safe i would recommend you
check out ring you know about the ring
video doorbell because i've told you
about it for many years it's this
incredible technology where you can see
and speak to whoever is at your door
whether you're in the house or outside
the house or on the road somewhere so i
was on the road i was on the road
yesterday got back but i was so glad to
know that my wife and baby and home are
safe
not only that they can see see whoever
is outside the door before they open the
door
but that with the ring alarm
you can
you can keep tabs on every inch of your
house wherever you are protect your home
not just in terms of security the way we
all think about it but from freeze from
fire from flood
ring has this whole
powerful alarm system
what they charge for one full year of
professional monitoring with ring alarm
that's about the price you would pay for
one month on the old kind of alarm
systems
go get the best deals right now deck the
halls walls doors and windows with the
best deals of the year on the
award-winning ring alarm go to ring.com
knowles kennedy wles get a great deal on
the ring alarm security kit today that's
ring.com
knowles
speaking of getting caught
do you know that there's a trial right
now going on
of guillain maxwell gelane maxwell the
partner in crime to jeffrey epstein who
totally killed himself
of his own volition
act it was accidentally permitted to
happen in that manhattan correctional
facility totally totally killed himself
and if you say otherwise you're a crazy
conspiracy theorist you know jeffrey
epstein the guy who had creepy pedo
island where he invited all the world
leaders and
largely democrat some republicans do but
largely democrats and libs
you know so elaine maxwell now is still
alive which is impressive and she's
she's on trial
we have not discussed the trial very
much on this show it's been going on for
about a week now
the reason i haven't discussed the trial
is one i'm still holding out hope that
the deep state will give me a big
payment not to talk about everyone's on
the take from the deep state except me
how come no one's offering me any money
come on i'll i'll play ball guys come on
no they won't call me no the reason i
haven't talked about it
is not because the story isn't
interesting and titillating and
terrifying and creepy
it's because there's there's no new
information
this is the scariest part of all
this we're not learning anything
what are we learning in in the trial
they're naming all the names of the
people who were on epstein's
airplanes we already knew that we knew
all those people were on the airplanes
we're finding out that jeffrey epstein
gillane maxwell visited the clinton
white house a lot
yeah we already knew that gillane was at
chelsea clinton's wedding
which we've known for years which the
media knew for years and years before
they would even touch the story it was
only a handful of conservatives who
would say hey what about this creepy guy
jeffrey epstein then finally
we know
all of this
that's what's so depressing about
the whole affair
we know
that the ruling class is deeply
implicated in the affairs of jeffrey
epstein this bizarre international man
of mystery who has apparently strange
ties to international intelligence who
we don't really know where he got his
money from we know he was surveilling
and blackmailing people it was
everything about it is just so we know
he got a sweetheart deal when he was
first brought up on the weird sex
charges we know that the united states
attorney at the time
under bush said uh jeffrey epstein
belongs to intelligence
so don't don't touch him and he gets
this sweetheart deal and then finally
they get him again some years later
after that we know all of that
so we know
the ruling class knows that we know
and we know that the ruling class knows
that we know
and it just doesn't matter this is why
that the meme jeffrey epstein didn't
kill himself this is why it became a
meme
right because no one thinks that this
guy was just sort of accidentally
allowed to kill himself and whoops the
camera that was on his cell just
accidentally went out and whoops the
guards that were checking on him just
accidentally
fell asleep
right at the perfect time so that no one
believes that
and the ruling class doesn't care
because what are you going to do about
it
what are you going to do
you know when when you look at the
intelligence community
component of all of this
i'm reminded of that phrase from chuck
schumer
right when the deep state you know it's
not the deep state's not a conspiracy
theory it's just the administrative
agencies with a particular focus on the
intelligence community we know that that
exists and that they have priorities
that they can pursue regardless of who
is in the white house and we know that
they can undermine duly elected
presidents they did it to trump they
cooked up a totally fake steel dossier
this and they used that as an excuse to
spy on him and to undermine his
administration and to plant lots of
bogus theories that got the guy
impeached twice
but
regardless
what are you gonna do about it
what are you
going to do about it nothing
chuck schumer the line from chuck
schumer was don't go up against the
intelligence community they can get you
nine ways from sunday
and he was being honest they can it's a
very powerful force
in not just american politics but in
global politics
so that's why we what is there to talk
about there's nothing to talk the real
story is not whatever creepy massage
jeffrey epstein got on petto island
the real story is
how did epstein become so powerful where
did he get his money
how did he so successfully blackmail
these people
what
what privileges did he get because he
had all this dirt on everybody who was
backing him
now speaking of ways to fight back
against the deep state not i'm not just
talking about the intelligence community
here now i'm talking about the entire
blob the whole just administrative
apparatus you know the fouchies of the
world
right fauci is a deep state or two
seven presidents come along dr fauci
remains
highest paid employee of the federal
government
crafting national policy in a more
significant way than
this president right joe biden said i
will never ever fire dr fauci
it can't be done
the last president trump didn't fire dr
fauci
and fouchy outlasted him
so how do we fight back against this
stuff how do we return to some semblance
of constitutional government
if people still want to do that at all
well ron desantis is showing the way in
florida ron desantis
just posted a picture of a health care
worker
governor de santa said jeff a florida
doctor i met in brandon at the special
session bill signing remember he did
that whole thing in this random town
called brandon florida i don't know why
just a coincidence probably
he was suspended from his job due to
biden's mandate he has now been
reinstated due to our efforts to stop
this heavy-handed federal mandate
freedom has a home here in florida
ron desantis is such a good politician
it's insane first of all
it's the right thing to do
it is the right thing to do to give
these health care workers their jobs
back
just because they don't want to take the
fouchy algae
they were fired because they didn't want
to take the fouchyache the former the
heroes the great wonderful heroes who
the dems just threw under the bus the
minute they wouldn't comply with their
ridiculous
demands and so desantis goes in it's the
right thing to do it's extremely smart
politics
and
the way that he's doing this
personalizes it
right what was the the old line you'd
hear from soviet russia
one person dead is a tragedy
five people dead is a tragedy a million
people dead as a statistic when we just
hear these you know fifty thousand
workers laid off because of the
fouchiauchi fifty hundred thousand it
doesn't mean anything uh what do i care
about fifty thousand i can't even
visualize that but but that guy i can
care about what's his name jeff
that's wrong for jeff to lose his job
and so desantis is saying you want this
guy to lose his job just because he
won't go along with fauci no he
shouldn't and the states should be
fighting back against this sort of thing
and and desantis has really led the way
in terms of people at the level of state
government no one has done it better
than desantis
speaking of fighting back and speaking
of of weird sex stuff actually there's a
really encouraging poll that just came
out from politico and morning consult
this with regard to abortion the supreme
court might right now may overturn or
overrule roe versus wade and planned
parenthood vkc there's a there's a
decent chance i spent a long time
talking about this last night with
senator ted cruz on our podcast verdict
so that that episode will be coming out
sometime in the next couple of weeks
and senator cruz is
hopeful he thinks there's a very good
chance he's more hopeful after the oral
arguments in the new abortion case than
he was beforehand
so let's say there's a chance well at
that point it will it will return the
issue to the state level and here's one
here's the biggest fear
that republicans have about the court
over ruling roe vs wade they fear that
right now the democrats look terrible
their poll numbers are in the gutter the
republicans are looking really really
great to win back the house in 2022 in
the white house in 2024
but
if next spring the supreme court
overrules row maybe that electoral
advantage will disappear because the
democrats will be so motivated to go out
and vote to kill babies and that that
they'll actually keep the house maybe
and they'll keep the senate and they'll
maybe keep the white house in 2024.
the polls don't back this up
no one
no no real people actually vote on
abortion
to support abortion
political elites do in the democratic
party very
ardent
blue-haired political activists do blue
haired meaning the young crazy radical
people not the older women i know it's
confusing when you refer to the blue
hairs
those guys care but those are very small
groups in terms of the
great number of actual voters
no one votes on this
according to politico
42 of respondents to their poll
said they would vote for a candidate who
does not align with their views on
abortion 42 percent we're told this is
the most important
you know touchstone pivotal issue that
will decide elections 42 percent don't
care whatsoever
only 32 percent said that that a
candidate's stance on abortion will
determine their vote
now a candidate's stance on abortion
very well might determine my vote as a
pro-lifer okay i think that's true for a
lot of people in the pro-life movement
but that's 32 percent of all americans
i'm just not convinced this is going to
be a decisive issue another 26 percent
were unsure or had no opinion on the
matter i have long suspected that this
was the case most people don't like
abortion even the ones who will go along
with it and support it they acknowledge
it's a bad thing right they're at the
very least of the idea that it should be
safe and rare safe legal and rareism
they're not the shout your abortion
crowd is a very small very insane
political minority and if this if this
poll is true then the left is absolutely
devastated politically
because it means that their their one
big issue that they're hanging their
hopes on
is a mirage for them at the at the
electoral level you know
when you want to cover up
when you want to feel really good when
you want to present yourself to the
world and you want to feel comfortable
doing it you should check out
misson and maine i love mizzen and maine
and here's why
i
love dress shirts okay i love the look
of dress shirts i am basically of the
opinion that a man should never walk out
in public without a collar on okay so at
least at least a polo shirt all right
but
you know you can't you can't work out in
that kind of clothing generally speaking
you know not that i work out a whole lot
but you know you can't really do that
you can sometimes the feel just isn't
great and they feel kind of rigid and
stuff well so miss it in maine fixed all
of this they've got the comfort and
flexibility of your favorite athletic
wear with the fit and style of a custom
dress shirt it's lightweight it's
breathable it's moisture wicking
it is really incredible stuff especially
you know i'm a member of a particularly
perspiring community known as the
italian americans and so if you do uh
sweat a little bit
their stuff is absolutely incredible i
love it it looks great the style is
exceptional and you will never feel a
more comfortable shirt in your life the
polos or the oxford shirts whether
you're updating your wardrobe to head
back to the office or you're just
looking for a new winter flannel there's
great news
if you go to mizinandmaine.com right now
and use promo code knowles you'll get 35
bucks off any regular price order of 125
or more that's 30 bucks off when you go
to m-i-z-z-e-n-a-n-d-m-a-i-n.com
use promo code knowles you know we here
at the daily wire are suing joe biden
very effectively by the way and we're
the lead plaintiffs and it's going very
well we have a goal of reaching 1
million signatures
this would provide a major boost to our
legal challenge
we have over 700 000 signatures so far
we need your help to cross the finish
line so please sign the petition at
dailywire.com do not comply and then
share our petition with all of your
friends and family
let's send a message so loud that the
biden administration can't ignore us
also
you've got to get matt walsh's book
matt walsh is the beloved best-selling
children's author and best-selling
number one best-selling lgbtq author on
amazon it's sold out within the first 24
hours
even though it's sold out though you can
reserve your copy at amazon
to get your hands on the next badge that
we'll be shipping out soon head on over
to amazon reserve your copy of johnny
the walrus today we'll be right back
with a lot more
for many years
the republican party elite believed that
pro-life advocacy was a fringe issue
that was going to hurt them electorally
and it was really going to turn off
people and the minute you mentioned
supporting life you were just going to
lose elections because so many people
were were motivated by
defending abortion and it's just not
true and here's my there are polls that
show that that's not true but
here's some really good evidence that
it's not true
south dakota republican governor
christie gnome is appealing a district
court ruling that stops the state from
enforcing part of a state law that would
require a woman to consult with a crisis
pregnancy center before having an
abortion so it's this very very modest
pro-life law it's good pro-life law it's
very very modest and some federal court
strikes it down so so christine in south
dakota
is
is taking this further up the courts
okay
i have no doubt that christina is
pro-life i'm not really not questioning
her pro-life bonafides
but one thing that we have learned about
governor gnome in recent
months and years
is that she is a little more of the
moderate variety of republican she's a
little more of the risk-averse variety
of republican that doesn't want to get
terribly involved in the cultural issues
and she's going to squish a little bit
on for instance transgenderism and she's
going to say no it's okay we can let
boys compete against girls at the
college level and i don't want to upset
the chamber of commerce too much she's
she's a moderate governor i really don't
even mean this to disparage her
you know we need we need a big coalition
of republicans but
the reason yeah whatever whatever they
say we need to let's bring in all the
moderates okay fine
but pro-life is a winning issue
and
no matter what christinom's views on
pro-life i have no reason to question
that she supports life
i suspect that the fact that this is a
winning issue is playing into her
calculation that it is so mainstream now
to support life
and to oppose abortion or to discourage
abortion that even the moderates even
the risk-averse
are doing it
something has changed a thai district
you're seeing it in the courts you're
seeing it at the level of electoral
politics you're seeing it in
grassroots advocacy
it is totally cool it's totally
mainstream to be pro-life that overton
window has shifted
considerably
not just since roe v wade even since i
was a kid
very very mainstream now speaking of
the various factions of the gop
my friend dan crenshaw is under fire
right now because of comments he made
about freedom caucus and the
conservatives and the moderates and
the comments he made are wrong
so i'm not going to defend the comments
he made
but i am going to
offer an exit ramp to people who have
fallen into the same sort of error that
unfortunately dan has in this case take
a listen
there's two types of members in congress
there's performance artists there's
legislators
now the performance artists are the ones
that get all the attention but the ones
you think are more conservative because
they know how to say slogans real well
they know how to recite the lines that
they know that our voters want to hear
let me tell you guys something in the
first two years of trump's presidency
when republicans were in control when
every single time we were voting on
donald trump's agenda
who do you think was at the top of that
list voting with trump and who do you
think was at the bottom
a lot of names you would recognize are
at the bottom of that list
a lot of names you would recognize are
at the top of that list
number two it's probably going to make
you cringe a little bit it's adam
kensinger
voting with trump almost 99
he was number two
but it was at the bottom
everybody in the freedom caucus
all of them we have grifters in our
midst
i don't think he's a terrible awful guy
who necessarily needs to be cast into
the outer darkness where there is
wailing and gnashing of teeth i think
there are actually a fair number of
republicans and people to the right of
center who would go along with this kind
of thinking
and i just think it's because of a
misperception of what's really going on
right on two fronts
both on
the trump administration and on the
members of congress so he says he says
adam kinzinger who is
just disgraceful just an absolutely
disreputable squish
he's just he's just awful he makes liz
cheney look like ronald reagan okay it's
just he's just terrible he's saying well
kinzinger voted with the trump agenda a
lot of the time
yeah sure he did i have no doubt about
that
trump did a lot of things lest we forget
that weren't that great i gave a speech
on one of them
just a couple of days ago at the
colorado christian university one of the
trump administration's signature
achievements was a jailbreak bill it was
a bill to let criminals out of prison
i don't say this to dis trump trump is
one of the toughest conservative
politicians i've seen in my lifetime i
admire him greatly i voted for him twice
but that was a bad bill he shouldn't
have voted for that or he shouldn't have
promoted that there were i think squish
elements in his administration that
promoted it and he went along with it
and it was a bad idea
a fair bit of the trump administration
agenda in part because he was
constrained by the establishment
arm of the gop a fair bit of it was just
the kind of regular old chamber of
commerce moderate stuff that we've seen
before and so so sure you can have
you can have a voting record where you
align with even someone like trump a lot
of the time but on some crucial issues
you might you might break and so what
what dan is saying here is there's a
difference between the show voters
and the real serious legislators and
those eccentric freedom caucus people
they're just show boaters who talk a
good game but they're not really
talented or whatever and the ones who
are
squishes like kinzinger or liz cheney
they're the real serious legislators and
i just think
that dan is
overstating the shortcomings of
conservatives and i think he is
overstating the virtues of the squishes
okay
it's it's very easy to pile on someone
like lauren bobert another friend of
mine or
marjorie taylor green it's very easy all
the media they found her facebook posts
and she has said some kooky things in
the past and so we got to pile on it's
very easy to do that especially when
it's being repeated by the the left-wing
media all the time
because they seem they're not polished
they're not sophisticated they're not
they say things that are a little
eccentric that even their supporters
sometimes say oh that was a little far
oh i don't know about that oh gosh i how
can i defend that
but
i think their hearts are in the right
place i think generally those
conservatives have their finger on the
pulse of what actually matters i i think
that uh
generally they do a good job
and i think generally the squishes
don't have their finger on the pulse of
what actually matters and i think on
even if they vote 99 of the time with
the conservatives on those crucial
issues they squish and what they end up
doing people like liz cheney and adam
kinzinger is they end up serving merely
as court jesters in the kingdom of
liberalism on the crucial political
matters when it really matters on the
presidential election on impeachment on
the january 6th nonsense what do they do
they ignore the republican party they
ignore the conservative base they do
worse than ignore it they denigrate the
conservative base they go on cnn of all
places and waste all of their time
attacking fellow republicans
on the import when it counts not just on
voting to cut taxes which everyone can
agree on
not just on the easy votes but on the
really tough ones the january 6th
committee or whatever crap nancy pelosi
is pushing on the really important
moments
kenzinger and liz cheney
squish
and how do they squish in the most
flamboyant showboaty way possible you
think marjorie taylor green is a
showboater tune in to cnn to watch adam
kinzinger
it's like watching a drag show it's like
it's so
it's so over the top and sensationalist
but but it doesn't seem that way all the
time because of this facade that the
left-wing establishment puts on where
kinsinger he's the very serious one you
know when he wears a tie and he speaks
in these very serious tones and he's
he's oh and then and then whoever the
lib interviewer is they'll just it's
really serious and they'll talk about
january 6 the greatest insurrection
ever
whatever you think about january 6th
not only was it not
the most dangerous insurrection in
america in history
it wasn't the most dangerous
insurrection in america that year
wasn't that would be blm and antifa that
burned city after city for six to eight
months that it's not even close it's not
even close
okay
so i understand
the reason i wanted to take a moment to
talk about this is because i don't
i don't think that whenever a
right winger goes in and starts you know
saying lines that you might hear on cnn
that necessarily we need to just
throw them overboard or or push them
even further in in that direction i
think we have to offer an exit ramp and
say look i get
why you can look at an adam kinzinger
when he goes on cnn
and
and and say oh gosh he seems so serious
i get how you can
be tricked into that
i get how you can see a news report
about marjorie taylor green's facebook
posts and you could be tricked into
thinking this is a terrible awful person
and a threat to america
but it's it's just not true
it's just not true
that adam kinzinger and liz chaney are
not more serious legislators than
marjorie taylor greene or lauren boba
they're much less serious legislators
okay they are much more flamboyant show
boaters okay it's just that the show
that we're watching is
is purporting to be reality but that
show is on c it's crafted by cnn and big
tech and it's just
it's just bogus speaking of the house
freedom caucus
paul gosar
paul gosar is member of the house
freedom caucus he's one of the more
right-wing members of congress
he has come out
to decry the treatment
of those alleged insurrectionists and
terrorists
from january 6th
it's been nearly a year has passed since
the treatment of political prisoners
held in detention facilities in
washington dc in relation to the events
on january january 6 and it is appalling
the physical conditions described by my
friends of these inmates can only be
described as inhumane these are not
hardened thugs murderers or gang members
with long histories of crimes these are
not unruly or dangerous violent
criminals these are dads brothers
veterans teachers
all political prisoners who continue to
be persecuted endure the pain of unjust
suffering mr biden attorney general
garland why are you so interested in
ruining the lives of these folks instead
of equal justice
why won't you publicly release the hours
and hours of video surveillance taken on
january 6th
what are you afraid of what are you
hiding
the heart of this country is equal
treatment especially by the courts
the public demands and the defendants
deserve equal justice under the law
what is being described by these
political prisoners is nothing short of
human rights violation
the silence from the aclu and amnesty
international is deafening
i gave this speech on america's
under-incarceration problem he gave that
speech at colorado christian a couple
days ago you can watch it on youtube it
was it was with yaff young america's
foundation at the centennial institute
there
and
one of the arguments
for letting criminals out of jail that
the libs and some of the squishes put
forward is that america has the highest
incarceration rate in the world we have
the highest
prison population in the world
so therefore
we obviously have to let some of them
out of prison
the question that matters is not how
many people are in prison the question
that matters is what kind of people are
in prison
are violent thugs in prison good they
should be that's where that's where
violent thugs are supposed to go
or is it
it political dissidents who are in
prison like we see in china well that
would be bad that's not exactly the kind
of thing that you want america generally
does not imprison political dissidents
the nearest thing we have to political
dissidents in prison right now are the
january 6th people
and it's not because they didn't do
anything wrong i'm sure a great many of
them did do things that were wrong it's
not that they're totally innocent and
they're in there
merely for their political views it's
that they're in the can on trumped-up
charges
so
blmmers go in and loot stores and burn
buildings and
and burn hole cities down
and they get off the hook
in manhattan and in the bronx
they are released from prison
or they're not or their charges are just
missed or they're greatly reduced and
that's happened that's happened for most
of them who were arrested last year
meanwhile the january sixers who go in
and they i don't know they've got the
horn hat on and they dance around and
maybe they take some pictures and write
those people maybe they break a window i
don't know those people are thrown into
solitary confinement indefinitely one of
them was killed one of them was shot by
a cop
the people on january 6 did not kill
anybody
the only the only people who were killed
in that political violence was was
ashley babbitt from who was one of the
january 6th
same cannot be said of blm who killed
dozens of people so it's that it's the
nearest thing we have
to imprisoning political dissidence here
and
and the house freedom caucus those
eccentric showboating people they're the
ones calling it out
okay and it's and it requires a lot of
political guts to do that because
because the media have crafted this
narrative but it's it's very important
to to call it like it is right now okay
it's if you're stuck in the echo chamber
of the mainstream
of the establishment media legacy me the
left-wing media if you're stuck it then
it's it's it's a little difficult to
perceive that but
but if the right builds builds its own
media apparatus if the right actually
goes in and highlights important stories
and tells the stories that the the left
doesn't want them to then then one can
notice it a little more clearly
speaking of crime
you know that there is this crime wave
going on all over the west coast
there is a an organized crime wave where
looters are going in and just robbing
stores cvs walgreens that kind of thing
aoc was just asked about this said well
what you know you're all about
abolishing the police and abolishing
prisons and letting all the criminals
out but there's all this this huge crime
spree going on isn't that a problem and
so aoc's response
is not
to
change her position
her response is not to say oh yeah
you're right okay i guess my ideas
didn't work maybe we shouldn't close all
the prisons
her maybe we shouldn't abolish the
police departments her response is also
not to double down and say well it's
perfectly fine it doesn't doesn't matter
sure there's a crime wave but
for my vision of justice that's what we
need to have
her response is just to deny
reality her response is to just put her
head in the sand put her fingers in her
ears and say la la la la la i can't hear
you i can't hear you
she said quote
a lot of these alligator i don't do a
good aoc impression a lot of these
allegations of organized retail theft
are not actually panning out
i believe it's a walgreens in california
cited it but the data didn't back it up
that's what she's saying it's just it's
just not real it's just fake so it's
being made up by the right-wing media
echo chamber is it
is it
so the the associated press report the
associated press you know that
infamously right-wing news outlet the
associated no pretty left-wing actually
says quote national retail groups last
month estimated the annual losses to be
in the tens of billions of dollars from
this stuff
just last friday authorities in
the
san francisco bay area conducted what
they described as one of the largest
retail theft busts in california history
they uncovered upwards of eight million
dollars worth of merchandise from cvs
target and walgreens that's just in the
san francisco bay area so you might say
yeah sure retailers are losing billions
but you know it's kind of a weird year
and maybe it's because people aren't
shopping as much well
how do you explain the san francisco
the san francisco cops finding eight
million dollars worth of stolen
merchandise that's not just a guy here
or there going in to get some bread for
his family that is an organized crime
spree that is being that is being done
by gangs of criminals and it is being
encouraged by left-wing politicians
the lib way of solving problems is is to
deny that the problems exist at all
i don't think i'm being hyperbolic here
their way of solving problems is to deny
that they exist at all and hope they go
away or hope that people don't notice
this is true of abortion
the way to solve the problem of abortion
to deal with the problem is to pretend
that a baby isn't a baby we can see the
baby on the sonogram we know it's a baby
we know philosophically it's a baby we
know
scientifically it's a baby but what they
say is nope never mind i
have this ideological vision and so i'm
going to have to deny the reality of
that baby and just not acknowledge it la
la la i can't hear you on crime well
this is what aoc is doing no it's not
it's just not happening it's not real if
you say it's real you're a racist or
whatever it's not happening la la la la
la education you've got these failing
schools what is what is the left say
nope no problem
get rid of charter schools get rid of
homeschooling yeah there's no
nothing that you
will do to reform education is
acceptable because there's no problem in
the first place la la la failing schools
people's lives being ruined
transgenderism
a man
pretends to be a woman thinks he's a
woman wants to be a woman
but he's a man well no he's not la la la
la la we're going to deny that reality
doesn't
it doesn't work nobody benefits from
denying reality
but so much of the left political
program
is to
try to redefine reality right that's the
purpose of political correctness is to
redefine reality by redefining all of
the words
john f kennedy when he says in his
speech his famous speech that was
repeated by countless democrat
politicians some people see things that
are and say why i dream things that
never were and say why not
right where he's actually quoting a play
by george bernard shaw and and the line
which kennedy didn't know is the line is
coming from a serpent in the garden of
eden tempting eve he's quoting the devil
he's saying it as though it's
inspirational
some people see reality and accept it
but i
i ignore reality and indulge in fantasy
and that's really great that's what he's
saying
speaking of the garden of eden that's
what whitaker chambers said he said
communism
is not the newest political ideology
it's the second oldest began in the
garden of eden when the serpent told ev
ye shall be his gods
you shall be forget reality
you you in your own mind you will craft
reality doesn't work out very well
hasn't worked out for any of those
people going back to the garden of eden
actually has not worked out very well at
all speaking of crime
and of denying reality
i've got to get to the juicy smolette
trial i've got to get to it it's much
more important than the elaine maxwell
trial if you ask me because we actually
are learning new things so jesse
smellette now he's changing his story a
million times and apparently had a
little bit of a weird relationship with
those dudes that he set up to go pretend
to rob him and say it's maggot country
even though they were giant you know
they pretended to be white supremacists
but they were giant nigerian dudes
so
now what what smolette is trying to do
to get off
on this trial is he's just trying to
pester the prosecutor and play the race
card and play the victim
so the prosecutor here was reading text
messages from jessie smilette
right these are messages to and from
jesse smollett and in it jesse smilet
uses the n-word you know the n-word the
n-word it's the only word that we're not
allowed to say it has the sacred
significance of the name of god for the
ancient israelites we're not allowed to
ever say the n-word but jesse smallett
said the n-word and so the prosecutor
reading the texts says the n word
and then jesse smallett says hey you
can't use that word don't stop using
that word stop using the word that i
used and the prosecutor said well i'm
not good what do you want me i'm reading
your texts dude again no say a different
word call it the n word don't say the n
word you have to call it the n word you
know the e n word
and the prosecutor says no i think i'm
just going to read the text i'm not
going to edit your language
this is
a perfect example of
the logic that animates modern
liberalism and leftism don't do what i
did hey you can't do what i did kind of
ties in with the freedom caucus stuff
because the freedom caucus tends to take
the political fight to the left and then
people who are a little bit more
moderate or a little more genteel they
say well we can't do that that's wrong
that's we can't we can't engage in some
of the tactics that the left engages and
that would then would be just like them
and
basically they're saying we need to
indulge in this kind of no don't don't
do what i did but it's not going to work
we should never do things that are
immoral or unjust but as a tactical
matter we can't just let the libs get
away with everything we can't let them
get away with having their own
completely different set of standards
than the ones they hold us by whether
that is in the courts whether that is in
prisons whether that is in the media
whether that is in politics generally
can not
do it got to take the fight to the libs
i'm michael nolsas the michael knowles
she'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 21.
today on the ben shapiro show joe
biden's poll numbers swirl the drain the
u.s surgeon general warns of a mental
health crisis among young americans and
we talk about the true causes of our
civilizational malaise that's today on
the bench bureau shall give it a listen